This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The future of architecture is the future of the human race. The two are one. If humanity has a future, it is architecture. That is architect Frank Lloyd Wright, who never shied away from making grand statements about architecture. Or himself. Right believe that the buildings we live in affect the kinds of people we become, the tastes we have, and the comforts we seek. And he said that he could rebuild the entire culture of the United States.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。建筑的未来就是人类的未来。两者合二为一。如果人类有未来，那便是建筑。这就是建筑师弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特，他从不避讳对建筑发表宏论。或者谈论他自己。赖特相信，我们居住的建筑会影响我们成为什么样的人、我们的品味以及我们所追求的舒适感。他说过，他可以重塑整个美国的文化。
He claimed that he could change the nation by changing its architecture. I did say that, and it's true. It's amazing what I could do for this country. And a big part of his plan, his philosophy, his proposed building system, was called usonia. That's reporter Avery Truffleman. And if you're like Euconia, what's that? Well, listen to part one of this story.
他声称可以通过改变建筑来改变这个国家。我确实说过，而且那是真的。我能为这个国家做的事情令人惊叹。他的计划、哲学和他提出的建筑体系中，很大一部分被称为“尤索尼亚”（Usonian）。那是记者艾弗里·特鲁夫曼。如果你在想“尤索尼亚”是什么？好吧，请听这个故事的第一部分。
That's the last episode of this show. This is part two, and it'll make a lot more sense after part one. But to summarize, Euconian homes were simple, but beautiful, custom homes designed to exist in harmony with the natural landscape around them. Wright had hoped to make these homes inexpensive enough to be affordable for middle and working class Americans. The first Euconian home cost $5,500, about $85 grand today. Wright built it for journalist Herbert Jacobson's wife Catherine in Madison, Wisconsin, in
那是本节目的上一集。这是第二部分，听过第一部分后，这一集会更有意义。但简单总结一下，尤索尼亚住宅是简单而美观的定制住宅，旨在与周围的自然景观和谐共存。赖特曾希望让这些住宅足够便宜，以至于中产阶级和工薪阶层的美国人都能负担得起。第一座尤索尼亚住宅造价为5500美元，相当于今天的8.5万美元左右。赖特在威斯康星州麦迪逊市为记者赫伯特·雅各布斯的妻子凯瑟琳建造了它，时间是
1937, and many would come after it, though none managed to be as inexpensive as the first one. But there are usonian houses in Alabama, California, Illinois, Massachusetts, Virginia, Pennsylvania, and beyond. The house that Herbert Jacobs built was the first of the usonian houses. Usonian, a right word meaning the United States is it ought to be at its democratic zenith. Nowadays, usonian houses may be seen the country wide. The right word meaning the United States is it ought to be at its democratic zenith. Nowadays, Usonian houses may be seen the country wide. You don't need a guidebook.
1937年，此后又建造了许多座，尽管没有一座能像第一座那样便宜。但在阿拉巴马州、加利福尼亚州、伊利诺伊州、马萨诸塞州、弗吉尼亚州、宾夕法尼亚州等地都有尤索尼亚住宅。赫伯特·雅各布斯建造的房子是第一座尤索尼亚住宅。“尤索尼亚”是赖特创造的一个词，意指美国应当处于其民主的巅峰状态。如今，尤索尼亚住宅遍布全国。这个赖特创造的词意指美国应当处于其民主的巅峰状态。如今，尤索尼亚住宅遍布全国。你不需要导游手册。
You'll know when you see one. Long, low, part of the very earth. You can practically hear the house boasting, designed by Frank Lloyd Wright. But that old timey announcer actually doesn't have a quite right. They're not all designed by Frank Lloyd Wright. Towards the end of his life, Bright would become preoccupied with large commissions,
当你看到它时，你就会认出来。修长、低矮，仿佛是大地的一部分。你几乎可以听到房子在自夸：由弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特设计。但那位老派播音员其实说得不太对。它们并非全部由弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特设计。在他生命的最后阶段，赖特开始专注于大型委托项目，
things like the Marin Soek Center and the Guggenheim. He would have less time to focus on his vision for Eusonia. But Wright's ideas about living in harmony with nature, using organic materials in a modern way, and creating affordable democratic housing had inspired a new generation of architects so much so that they would go on to found an entire community based on righty and principles. Turn right onto Eusonia Road.
比如马林县市政中心和古根海姆博物馆。他将没有太多时间专注于他对尤索尼亚的愿景。但赖特关于与自然和谐共处、以现代方式使用有机材料以及创造经济适用型民主住房的理念，激励了新一代建筑师，以至于他们后来建立了一个完全基于赖特原则的社区。在尤索尼亚路右转。
Nestled in Levy Hills near Pleasantville, New York, about an hour north of Manhattan, is a little village called Eusonia. All the homes have low flat roofs. They're tucked away into the trees, so you can hardly see them on lush summer days. It almost looks like some sort of Star Wars planet, fit for suburban Ewoks. There's no big welcome sign, no gift shop or leaflet, But in the middle of the community, there is a plaque. Eustonia Holmes, a cooperative was founded in 1944 by idealistic young families to pursue the dream of owning a modern affordable home in the country
坐落在纽约州普莱森特维尔附近的利维山，距离曼哈顿以北约一小时车程，有一个叫尤索尼亚的小村庄。所有的房子都有低矮的平屋顶。它们隐藏在树丛中，在郁郁葱葱的夏日里几乎看不见。它看起来几乎像某种《星球大战》里的星球，适合郊区的伊沃克人居住。这里没有巨大的欢迎标志，没有礼品店或传单，但在社区中心有一块牌匾。尤索尼亚住宅合作社成立于1944年，由一群理想主义的年轻家庭创立，旨在追求在乡村拥有现代、经济适用房的梦想，
following World War II. The cooperative was started by a couple of right disciples who had studied at Frank Lloyd Wright School, Tally Esson, most notably a man named David Hanken. And although Wright would be involved with the project, it was Hanken who guided it, as the Black says, This land was acquired in December 1946 and in April 1947, Frank Lloyd Wright, the supervising architect, sent the unique site plan.
紧随第二次世界大战之后。该合作社由几位曾在弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特的塔里耶森学校学习过的赖特门徒发起，其中最著名的是大卫·汉肯。虽然赖特会参与该项目，但正如牌匾所言，是汉肯引导了它。这片土地于1946年12月购得，1947年4月，监督建筑师弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特寄来了独特的场地规划图。
The site plan put 40 some houses on circular properties without fences, so that the property boundaries would flow into each other. Homes wouldn't be on little square plots with white-picked fences. David Henken and his family looked for other similarly-minded people who could come and join their community and invest in it. And among those idealistic young people was Roland Reisley. He and his wife had just been married in 1950. We had no money, we had no children, we were both only children.
场地规划将40多栋房子放在没有围栏的圆形地块上，这样地块边界就会相互融合。住宅不会建在带有白色栅栏的小方块地块上。大卫·汉肯和他的家人寻找其他志同道合的人加入他们的社区并进行投资。在那些理想主义的年轻人中，就有罗兰·赖斯利。他和妻子刚于1950年结婚。“我们没钱，没有孩子，我们俩都是独生子女。”
We wanted to plant our roots and start a family. And we heard from a friend that there's a community in northern Westchester that's building affordable homes supervised by Frank Lloyd Wright. This building project had a communal mortgage. They would pay for the houses together. On land, they all owned. It's a cooperative. Let's take a look, curious.
“我们想扎根并组建家庭。我们从朋友那里听说，在威彻斯特北部有一个社区，正在建造由弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特监督的经济适用房。”这个建筑项目有共同抵押贷款。他们将共同支付房款。在他们共同拥有的土地上。这是一个合作社。让我们来看看，很好奇。
And we came up here, and there were already 10 or 11 homes that were near completion or beginning to be occupied. We were welcomed with open arms and the enthusiasm of the people who were here and talking about their project was infectious. And we were hooked. We decided that we'll join the community.
“我们来到这里，已经有10到11栋房子接近完工或开始有人入住。我们受到了热情的欢迎，这里的人们谈论他们项目时的那种热情具有感染力。我们被吸引住了。我们决定加入这个社区。”
But it wasn't all a big romantic adventure. It was a real risk. First of all, first was radical. It's not these days that's called mid-century modern, but the architecture then was radical. Meaning, these homes were so strange looking to the larger world that the people who chose to live in them were seen as radical. And in some ways they were. Some of them were lefty Jews from the Bronx with socialist ideals about land ownership. The true cooperative that we were was radical.
但这并非全是浪漫的冒险。这是一个真正的风险。首先，它很激进。如今这被称为“中世纪现代主义”，但当时的建筑风格是激进的。意思是，这些房子在外界看来太奇怪了，以至于选择住在里面的人被视为激进分子。在某些方面，他们确实如此。他们中有些人是来自布朗克斯的左翼犹太人，有着关于土地所有权的社会主义理想。“我们这个真正的合作社是激进的。”
True cooperative in the sense that no one owned their house? Yes. Also, this was a financial risk, since the houses were not as cheap as they were supposed to be. You're cooperating in the sense that no one owned their house? Yes. Also, this was a financial risk, since the houses were not as cheap as they were supposed to be. The supposed $5,000 cost will turn out it was not a realistic number. During and after World War II, materials and labor became more expensive, and the building of Euconian homes involved special skills and custom fixtures, and the houses ended up being double or triple their price estimates.
“真正的合作社是指没有人拥有自己的房子吗？”“是的。此外，这是一种财务风险，因为房子的价格并不像预期的那么便宜。”“你们合作的意思是没人拥有自己的房子？是的。此外，这是一种财务风险，因为房子的价格并不像预期的那么便宜。”原本5000美元的成本后来证明是一个不现实的数字。在第二次世界大战期间及之后，材料和劳动力变得更加昂贵，建造尤索尼亚住宅需要特殊技能和定制装置，最终房子的价格是预估价格的两到三倍。
The Reisley's house was over 20 grand, but the members of Euconia would not be deterred. We were determined to go forward with this, we were all very optimistic. Peel would come occasionally to see these houses under construction. You gotta come and see Insania. When Roland and his wife signed up for the community, they thought they'd work with one of the Taliesin graduates to design their house, not the master himself. We didn't dream of approaching Frank Lloyd Wright, I mean, really. Who would throw such a thing?
赖斯利家的房子花了2万多美元，但尤索尼亚的成员们并没有被吓倒。“我们决心继续推进，我们都非常乐观。”赖特偶尔会来看看这些在建的房子。“你一定要来看看尤索尼亚。”当罗兰和他的妻子报名加入社区时，他们以为会和塔里耶森的毕业生之一合作设计他们的房子，而不是大师本人。“我们做梦也没想过要接触弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特，我是说，真的。谁会做这种事？”
But Frank Lloyd Wright did, in fact, want to design Roland's house. They met up in New York and they exchanged letters and ideas about the plans and Roland went out to see Wright at Tally Esson. And he was a real person. You could talk to him. You could exchange a joke. I mean people don't see him that way. But there it was. Roland was 26. Wright was 83. He said, come on Roland, sit down. You're my client, I'm your architect. I'll redesign your house as many times as I have to until I've satisfied all of your needs. You have to speak up if you don't,
但弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特确实想设计罗兰的房子。他们在纽约见面，交换了关于计划的信件和想法，罗兰还去塔里耶森拜访了赖特。“他是一个真实的人。你可以和他交谈。你可以开个玩笑。我是说人们并不那样看他。但事实就是如此。”罗兰当时26岁。赖特83岁。“他说，来吧罗兰，坐下。你是我的客户，我是你的建筑师。我会重新设计你的房子，直到满足你所有的需求。如果你不提出来，你就必须说出来，”
you'll take what you get. Roland's house would be one of three in Eusonia, New York that Frank Lloyd Wright designed himself. About five years after the Riesley's moved in, when Roland and his wife had kids, Frank Lloyd Wright added an extension to their house. In fact, Roland is the last living owner of a Frank Lloyd Wright eustonian home built specially for him, and he still lives in it. I came to realize after some years living here that there had not been a day in my life when I didn't
“你就会得到什么是什么。”罗兰的房子将是纽约尤索尼亚三栋由弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特亲自设计的房子之一。在赖斯利一家搬进去大约五年后，当罗兰和妻子有了孩子，弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特为他们的房子增加了一个扩建部分。事实上，罗兰是最后一位于世的、拥有弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特专门为他建造的尤索尼亚住宅的业主，而且他至今仍住在里面。“住在这里几年后，我意识到，我生命中没有一天，”
see something beautiful, even the terrible days that occur in every life. The house is completely usonian, with a simple carport and sumptuous wooden walls that almost glow and one big main room and a tiny kitchen. It almost feels like you're outside because it has these big glass windows with long roof overhangs to draw the eye out towards the thick forest of trees just outside. I think that it has had an effect on me, in many ways.
“看不到美丽的东西，即使是每个人生活中都会遇到的糟糕日子。”这栋房子是典型的尤索尼亚风格，有一个简单的车棚、几乎会发光的华丽木墙、一个巨大的主房间和一个小厨房。它感觉就像在户外一样，因为它有巨大的玻璃窗和长长的屋檐，将视线引向窗外茂密的森林。我认为它在很多方面对我产生了影响。
The neuroscientists say that that kind of sense reduces stress and is good for your emotional health. And maybe good for physical health too, I'm 92 years old, I'm pretty good shape in 92. And I attribute that partly, I mean, who knows. I'd like to attribute that to experience beauty around me for most of my life, which is quite remarkable. As Roland sees it, Frank Lloyd writes idea that better architecture could create a better way of life, has been entirely true.
神经科学家说，那种感觉可以减轻压力，对你的情绪健康有好处。也许对身体健康也有好处，我92岁了，92岁时我的身体状况相当不错。我把这部分归功于——谁知道呢。我想把它归功于我生命中大部分时间里所经历的美，这非常了不起。正如罗兰所见，弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特认为更好的建筑可以创造更好的生活方式，这一点完全正确。
We could depend on each other if there was a problem or a need. The kids were all the adults by their first name. We used to say that children growing up here had 50 aunts and uncles in New Sonia. For the first 40 years of Euconia in New York, only 12 of the 48 houses changed hands. Six of those, the next generation members of the community. There were only two devices. I had to joke, they couldn't decide who'd get the house. But life started to move at different paces for people living in Euconia.
“如果遇到问题或需要，我们可以互相依靠。孩子们直呼所有成年人的名字。我们过去常说，在尤索尼亚长大的孩子有50个叔叔阿姨。”在纽约尤索尼亚的前40年里，48栋房子中只有12栋易主。其中六栋由社区的下一代成员接手。只有两起离婚。我不得不开玩笑说，他们无法决定谁该得到房子。但尤索尼亚居民的生活节奏开始变得不同。
Suddenly they weren't all new young families. They were all groups of people in different phases with different needs. And when it was time for homes to change hands, perspective buyers were thrown off by the cooperative nature of the village. In the first decades of euconia, members didn't own their homes. We decided very reluctantly to grant title to the individual home sites to each member while retaining all of our common land as a cooperative. And that made a big difference.
突然间，他们不再全是年轻的新家庭。他们成了处于不同阶段、有不同需求的人群。当房子需要易主时，潜在买家被村庄的合作性质吓跑了。在尤索尼亚的最初几十年里，成员们并不拥有他们的房子。“我们非常不情愿地决定将每个住宅地块的所有权授予每个成员，同时保留我们所有的公共土地作为合作社。”这产生了巨大的影响。
Suddenly people were more willing to look at them. But if you're not Roland Reisley and your house wasn't custom built for you by Frank Lloyd Wright himself, the Usonia houses can be a bit of an adjustment. Today, most of the homes in Usonia, New York have been expanded. Any and all new additions have been built in a Usonian style, using local materials, flat roofs, big glass windows, and writing sensibilities. They have to be built that way. While the outsides are not landmarked, they are governed by the board of Usonia.
突然间，人们更愿意考虑它们了。但如果你不是罗兰·赖斯利，而且你的房子不是由弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特亲自为你定制的，那么尤索尼亚住宅可能需要一点适应。今天，纽约尤索尼亚的大多数住宅都进行了扩建。所有的新增部分都是以尤索尼亚风格建造的，使用当地材料、平屋顶、大玻璃窗和赖特的审美感。它们必须那样建造。虽然外观没有被列为地标，但它们受尤索尼亚董事会的管理。
The insides are not at all. This is Evan Kingsley, he's one of the newcomers to Usonia. Relatively, he's been there since 2003. But I think for the most part, those of us who have chosen to move here are really sensitive to the aesthetic of the interior. But there's one specific part of the interior that has changed in a lot of the Usonian homes. We've completely redone the kitchen.
内部则完全不受限制。这是埃文·金斯利，他是尤索尼亚的新成员之一。相对而言，他从2003年就在那里了。“但我认为在很大程度上，我们这些选择搬到这里的人对室内美学非常敏感。”但室内有一个特定的部分在许多尤索尼亚住宅中发生了变化。“我们彻底重做了厨房。”
As was the case in most usonian homes, the kitchen in Evans' home was this little alcove, very efficient and very, very tiny. Right never realized that the whole family might actually wanna hang out in the kitchen. Nowadays, it's as much a place to gather as the living room or the dining room. Evans has added new tiling and appliances and expanded his kitchen, but not by much.
正如大多数尤索尼亚住宅的情况一样，埃文家里的厨房是一个小凹室，非常高效，也非常非常小。赖特从未意识到整个家庭可能实际上想在厨房里消磨时光。如今，它和客厅或餐厅一样，是一个聚会的地方。埃文增加了新的瓷砖和电器，并扩大了他的厨房，但幅度不大。
Well we bumped that wall out by taking some closet space away and we gained, I don't know, maybe 10 inches there. That's all that we gained in doing that. There are a smattering of usonian homes throughout the United States, some designed by right and some by his apprentices, but all following the same basic principles. And like Evan Kingsley's home, many of these other Euconian houses are hard to modify, because they're often governed by boards who are trying to preserve them as historic pieces of architecture.
“好吧，我们通过占用一些壁橱空间把那堵墙向外推了推，我们获得了，我不知道，大概10英寸吧。这就是我们所获得的一切。”美国各地散布着一些尤索尼亚住宅，有些由赖特设计，有些由他的学徒设计，但都遵循相同的基本原则。像埃文·金斯利的家一样，许多其他尤索尼亚住宅很难修改，因为它们通常由试图将其作为历史建筑进行保护的董事会管理。
And also, the owners themselves want to make sure they keep within the principles of the house. You have X number of cabinets, you don't have cabinets up at the top. They weren't put there and if you could add them, you would violate the principles. There's no Frank Lloyd Wright police who come around and look and see if you change the old stuff. That's a weird joke about it, but there isn't. That's Betty and John Moore.
而且，业主自己也想确保他们保持在房子的原则之内。“你有X个橱柜，你不能在顶部安装橱柜。它们原本不在那里，如果你加了它们，你就会违反原则。”没有弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特警察会到处查看你是否更换了旧东西。这是一个关于它的奇怪笑话，但确实没有。那是贝蒂和约翰·摩尔。
They live in Wisconsin and the house called Jacob's two. It's the second Euconian house that right designed for that journalist Herbert Jacobs. Yeah, well, you want to make sure that you can adapt to the house because it's not going to adapt to you. You aren't going to change it much. Like most Euconian homes, Jacob's two had a car port, big windows, an open plan, in concrete floors with a heating system in it. The floor is nice and cool now, so. What's the winner?
他们住在威斯康星州，房子叫“雅各布斯二号”。这是赖特为那位记者赫伯特·雅各布斯设计的第二座尤索尼亚住宅。“是的，好吧，你要确保你能适应房子，因为它不会适应你。你不会改变它太多。”像大多数尤索尼亚住宅一样，雅各布斯二号有一个车棚、大窗户、开放式布局和带有供暖系统的混凝土地板。“地板现在又凉又舒服，所以。冬天呢？”
You come downstairs with bare feet and it's nice and warm. I mostly wanted to play that clip because I love how Betty and John actually complete each other's sentences. Betty and John's house needed a lot of attention, which is why it was on the market for four and a half years before they bought it. Oh, everybody wanted to look at it. It's a curiosity, but nobody wanted to live here. They have been really not for everyone.
“你光着脚下楼，感觉又好又暖和。”我主要想播放这段录音，因为我喜欢贝蒂和约翰实际上互相补充对方句子的方式。贝蒂和约翰的房子需要很多关注，这就是为什么它在他们买下之前已经在市场上挂了四年半。“哦，每个人都想看看它。它是一个好奇心，但没人想住在这里。”它们确实不适合所有人。
The reason they sit on the market sometimes for so long is because people consider them a difficult living. That's John Eifler, an architect in Chicago who has restored a number of right houses, including Yusonia One. In order to preserve them, you sometimes have to modify them in order to make them more livable. But even experts like Eiffler have a tough time keeping track of how many Yusonia homes exist.
“它们有时在市场上停留那么久的原因是人们认为它们居住起来很困难。”那是芝加哥的建筑师约翰·艾夫勒，他修复了许多赖特的房子，包括尤索尼亚一号。“为了保护它们，你有时必须修改它们，以便让它们更适合居住。”但即使是像艾夫勒这样的专家，也很难追踪到底有多少尤索尼亚住宅存在。
So how many are there? I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I've't know. I don't know. I've heard numbers ranging from 27 to 140. It all depends on your definition of what an authentic Euconian house is. You could consider Euconia a period in Frank Lloyd Wright's
“那么有多少呢？我不知道。我不知道。我不知道。我听到的数字从27到140不等。这完全取决于你对什么是真正的尤索尼亚住宅的定义。”你可以把尤索尼亚看作是弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特生命中的一个时期，
life, a period in American architectural history, which would include the houses by the apprentices, or just a general architectural style. Depending on your definition, the number of Euconian houses continues to grow. In 2013, a new Euconian house was built on the campus of Florida Southern College. It was a design of rights from 1939, but constructed 74 years later, all according to rights, plans, and principles. Eusonia certainly never came to pass in the way that Frank Woodwright originally envisioned, with every American living in an affordable custom home.
美国建筑史上的一个时期，其中可能包括学徒设计的房子，或者仅仅是一种通用的建筑风格。根据你的定义，尤索尼亚住宅的数量在不断增加。2013年，佛罗里达南方学院的校园里建造了一座新的尤索尼亚住宅。那是赖特1939年的设计，但在74年后才建成，完全按照赖特的计划和原则。尤索尼亚当然从未以弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特最初设想的方式实现，即每个美国人都住在一栋经济实惠的定制住宅中。
And in fact, elements of the Eusonian home have evolved into something else entirely. So it is kind of true that Eusonia directly influenced the development of the ranch home. Oh, without a doubt, yes, I think so. Ranch style houses are all over the country, and nearly every suburb, they are horizontal, close to the ground, one story, they have an open floor plan with few walls. So it's not hard to see the similarities to Euconia. Although ranch homes are generally less inspired, they don't have the elegant details and they're made with standard materials.
事实上，尤索尼亚住宅的元素已经演变成了完全不同的东西。“所以尤索尼亚直接影响了牧场式住宅的发展，这在某种程度上是真的。”“哦，毫无疑问，是的，我想是这样。”牧场式住宅遍布全国，几乎每个郊区都有，它们是水平的，靠近地面，一层楼，它们有开放式的平面图，墙壁很少。所以不难看出与尤索尼亚的相似之处。虽然牧场式住宅通常灵感较少，它们没有优雅的细节，而且是用标准材料制成的。
Wright might not have been pleased the concepts of euconia got absorbed into, essentially the epitome of cookie-cutter suburban housing. But at least these houses really were affordable for the middle class, unlike all the euc houses after usonia one. After World War II, the American suburbs were full of ranch homes. There weren't that many variations after the war, and the suburban ranch home was pretty much it. I mean, that, unless you were living in some humongous mansion or something, everyone was living in ranch homes in Suburbia. It was a very prevalent form of housing. Frank Lloyd Wright died in 1959 at age 89,
赖特可能不会高兴尤索尼亚的概念被吸收进了本质上是千篇一律的郊区住宅的缩影中。但至少这些房子对中产阶级来说确实是负担得起的，不像尤索尼亚一号之后的所有尤索尼亚住宅。第二次世界大战后，美国郊区到处都是牧场式住宅。战后没有太多变化，郊区牧场式住宅基本上就是那样。我是说，除非你住在某种巨大的豪宅里，否则每个人都住在郊区的牧场式住宅里。这是一种非常普遍的住房形式。弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特于1959年去世，享年89岁，
three years after finishing Roland Reisley's house in New York. He died having created an American style for home building, away in which natural wood, bricks, and masonry are used in a simple, modifiable way, a way that is cozy, stylish, organic, and honest. His influence is there where you see lots of wood and stone and where you see big, open floor plans, where homes are oriented to the sun,
在他完成罗兰·赖斯利在纽约的房子三年后。他去世时创造了一种美式住宅建筑风格，一种以简单、可修改的方式使用天然木材、砖块和砖石的方式，一种舒适、时尚、有机且诚实的方式。他的影响力随处可见，当你看到大量的木材和石头，当你看到巨大的开放式平面图，当住宅朝向太阳，
or away from the street, where you see a structure built into a hill instead of on top of it, connected and responding to the landscape. And yes, whether he would have liked it or not, Frank Lloyd Wright's influence can be found in ranch homes in the suburbs, and in the details of all kinds of homes.
或者背对街道，当你看到结构建在山坡里而不是山顶上，与景观相连并做出响应时。是的，无论他是否喜欢，弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特的影子都可以在郊区的牧场式住宅中，以及各种住宅的细节中找到。
All around us, in ways right never imagined, Eusonia lives on. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Avery Trouffleman, which is refive, Delaney Hall, Emmith Fitzgerald, Sam Greenspan, and me Roman Mars. Katie Mingle is our senior editor, Kurt Colstead is our digital director, Teran Mazza is our office manager, and Sean Rial composed all original music for this episode. Special thanks this week to Jim Sharp, Sam Sharp, Ayal Podel, Josh Podel, Lloyd Trouffleman, Alison Churnow, and Jim Dennis. We are a project of 91.7K, LW in San Francisco, and produced on Radio Row.
在我们周围，以赖特从未想象过的方式，尤索尼亚依然存在。《99%隐形》本周由艾弗里·特鲁夫曼制作，参与者还有雷·法伊夫、德莱尼·霍尔、埃米斯·菲茨杰拉德、萨姆·格林斯潘和我罗曼·马尔斯。凯蒂·明格尔是我们的高级编辑，库尔特·科尔斯特德是我们的数字总监，泰兰·马扎是我们的办公室经理，肖恩·里亚尔为本集创作了所有原创音乐。本周特别感谢吉姆·夏普、萨姆·夏普、阿亚尔·波德尔、乔什·波德尔、劳埃德·特鲁夫曼、艾莉森·丘诺和吉姆·丹尼斯。我们是旧金山91.7K, LW的一个项目，在广播街制作。
In beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. One of the Vanguard shows in the radio topia trot is the heart. It's all about love and intimacy and how those two things intersect with our lives. Right now they're in the middle of a series about how femininity, femininity. That's right. Intersects with masculinity. It's called fancy. I love the idea of being able to like on a hot summer's day wear a skirt. If I want to wear a big chunky necklace one day I will wear it. If I want to paint a nail I'll do it. If it were socially acceptable for me to wear eyeliner I want to wear a big chunky necklace one day, I will wear it if I want to paint a nail, I'll do it. If it were socially acceptable for me to wear eyeliner, I would absolutely wear eyeliner.
在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。广播乌托邦（Radiotopia）系列中的先锋节目之一是《心》（The Heart）。它完全关于爱与亲密关系，以及这两者如何与我们的生活交织在一起。现在他们正在制作一个关于女性气质——女性气质，没错——如何与男性气质交织的系列。它叫《时髦》（Fancy）。“我喜欢这种想法，比如在炎热的夏日穿裙子。如果我想戴一条大粗项链，我就戴。如果我想涂指甲，我就涂。如果我戴眼线笔在社会上是可以接受的，我绝对会戴眼线笔。”
I just like the way it looks. Subscribe to The Heart and you can discover how bold and daring in both subject and form a podcast can be. Find it in all the radio topia shows. At the new radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet to me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram in Tumblr too. If you live in a eusony home, we would love to hear from you. Contact us through any of the aforementioned social media channels or you can always find us through our website
“我只是喜欢它看起来的样子。”订阅《心》，你可以发现播客在主题和形式上可以有多么大胆和前卫。在所有广播乌托邦节目中找到它。在新的radiotopia.fm。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PI org。我们在Instagram和Tumblr上也有账号。如果你住在尤索尼亚住宅，我们很乐意收到你的来信。通过上述任何社交媒体渠道联系我们，或者你总是可以通过我们的网站找到我们
Which right now has all kinds of extra frankloid-right articles and good stuff going on. at 99pi.org Radio Tapio. From PRX. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
目前网站上有各种关于弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特的额外文章和精彩内容，网址是99pi.org。来自PRX的广播乌托邦。你这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。